hi everyone i'm oscar isaac and i'm
ethan hawk and we are about to watch the
trailer of our new series moon night on
disney plus you ready yeah get the space
bar
let's do this
i can really do rubik's cube by the way
you're kind of like a genius man
okay this is creepy so far uh-huh i'm
liking it between my waking life
i'm liking knife
please sir can i have some more are you
laughing or crying
maybe we don't know
okay while you have restraints in your
bed that's not cool
little kid cudi come on
all right i'm losing it
that's my favorite shot right there's a
good one
you're bloody useless lucy she's like
the best
so funny with a v
stevie with a v
oh oh what was that that's
creepy you gotta
you gotta get more rest
thank you
lost the contact lens
hope you find it
thanks
this march
my birthday's in march it's a good sign
oh
the reflection what was that about uh
pyramid
crocodile yeah old flip phone you're
alive what's wrong with you mark
why did you call me mark
i look a little bit like brandon island
with dr moreau it's the best burger
[Music]
this chaos
that was a lot of self inflicted pain
egypt
embrace the chaos that's right oh i see
white
and there he is and all his glory who is
he yes
happy